hahaha how's Gomes my name is Pierre ah
welcome to gravity bone made by blender
games do you remember 30 flights of
lovin uploaded it maybe two weeks ago
one week ago it was a very weird
experience but a lot of fun I love that
game so much and is it really short it's
probably just gonna be like a 10 minute
video and this is the prequel it came up
before at least I don't know if the
prequel long seagull but all right start
new game let's do this by the end of the
video
oh hi I said this Annabelle gravity I
think what I love most about this game
is music and the style it's [ __ ] yeah
alright DASD miles to look but madness
is this
Tommy what madness SS alright I'm
believing oh hello the Saturday Club
business initiative wet work go to the
furnace room I feel like I'm playing
Minecraft is this minecraft hello where
are the mine pics this as far as time I
play minecraft I was getting notch
where's not he's supposed to be here
right ladies have you seen dodge he's on
the upper floor with a bunch of women oh
heck yeah I'm going okay
that's only [ __ ]
okay
maybe I get up I can wonderful all right
what's going on here buddy
furnace room furnace ha ha ha all right
I [ __ ] rock what do we do now
okay okay I get it
hello red hair okay yeah what if I don't
pick up the outfit ha ha ha
I'll just go naked I'll [ __ ] it I'm
wearing it hey it's disguise did I get a
mustache too baby
I want to watch that okay have you seen
notch or the man with red hair but
Alice's plays anyway there's this guy
she's beautiful
oh that is oh I'm sorry just gonna sneak
past you
okay hey what's up not want s drink it
nice unibrow by the way yeah
disgusting alright what's up I'm just
gonna yeah okay alright find the exit
well what the [ __ ] what different people
don't expect what one in Heaven's
all right so how do I find diamond in
this game I think I'm supposed to dig
down I'm not sure okay there we go
contract application thank you Toby's
composting hotline glass wall
successfully related to the target
individual okay get in the movie we can
because the Manitoba beast was clearly
laughing Amy asses across the galaxy yay
oh I get pinged invisible bike bonus
what the [ __ ] can someone go back and
read that I wish I could do that
alright that's cold
let's see what our next mission is
[ __ ] loving this okay
what is this Oh a new mission all right
a research snatch deep raid a furnace
room but okay
of course what do you think yes I do
agree with you what about you yeah that
is a very clever remark how about you
lady why you know speak woman what are
you reading her what's up passionless
moments are you a lesbo why do I get
okay she's rowing [ __ ] it
furnace room yep this is where I do my
[ __ ]
hell yeah [ __ ] what do I get
whoa calm down
Jason sky
what about these ooh ooh can I drop in
mrs. ah you can barely see the penis
come on
I have to drop faster penis is [ __ ]
alright I guess I gotta use this and
then plop just like in the movies
awesome
again hi hi hi huh whoa what's going on
here photographic the fibers okay all
right I'm gonna [ __ ] take so many
pictures you don't even know like I
don't even know what awesome moon all
right
oh well aren't you pretty
come at the mama clothes
nice what laughing uh yeah
small globba globba hey what's your
name's Marjorie that's a lovely name my
dear angel accredited Marjorie
yes that makes so much sense but
everyone knows virus but explode when
you take pictures of them all right
let's keep taking third picture ticket
hey what's up I'm gonna take a picture
of you so don't kill yourself I know
they're gonna be on Facebook and people
probably laughs sighs that but don't
nothing worth killing yourself over all
right don't know that poor bird
but I'm gonna upload your photos to
Facebook anyway
all right poplar look all right okay
what
what emojis [ __ ] [ __ ] 3:16 whoa
alright Bridget all right I can just
spin them out all right
[ __ ] Emily [ __ ]
whoa oh all right
what if we go now bucket oh okay this
yeah these are last one
what group adverse in there I don't get
it
all right what's your name Rodriguez I
don't trust you tell me what's your real
name is Tom a [ __ ] you'd rather kill
himself and tell me it's got to be a
really ugly name like hold on dad or
something
actually that name is the airport sorry
I don't think anyone whose name is rock
alumni working man die
Hey
first I'm like no no I got this [ __ ] is
getting sober
alright I guess I go here or do I going
back to the okay here we go
okay I'm back here cool
hey what's up you're still here girl you
want to sniff house man
how do you feel hahaha
exit sound alright ah I'm in stop was I
I didn't oh I'm doc I let them talk
Sarah see it hard so I can't take
bullets you son of a [ __ ] you set me up
didn't you
you [ __ ] Inez I could hit the
feed stock what do you do it oh don't
you dare Jake my camera come back here
what one and a half goddamn you a [ __ ]
got ok good come back in holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
fast stops each other
[Music]
all right chairs Brea's look at that oh
sorry I forgot I'm making a video this
game I [ __ ] love it it's so weird all
right hey Jack come back here
that son of a oh [ __ ] come back here
how the [ __ ] is she now love the music
that should go down I guess so son of a
[ __ ] and the hell am I now ha come back
here you [ __ ] you try to be cool and
[ __ ]
she smokes how can she be so fat lasers
quia cuidado ah
silly pewds always going to try stupid
[ __ ]
my apologies whoa
how is that even a train in the first
place
alright here we go don't cuidado ha ha
why didn't happen let's go out here oh
I'm sorry about your meatballs I think
why are you so sure what what is wrong
with Nick go to your doctor immediately
ok that's my boss
you're welcome I need that what the hell
come back it son of a [ __ ] is my bird
in my bird collection and my facebook
album and you're just jealous because my
facebook government is gonna be so much
more [ __ ] awesome than your Facebook
out that no I should be an actor in the
Maria this is so [ __ ] awesome I love
this me up no I need to know okay
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me huh I'm Phil Phil hey
card out his smiling face I uh I didn't
know what the hell is that
you should give me a kiss
[Music]
huh this game is just [ __ ] beautiful
Kalamata Mandela bravissimo
ah gravity bone by Brennan Chang the end
ah well that was [ __ ] beautiful it
was confusing as [ __ ] but it was [ __ ]
awesome alright uh I hope you enjoyed it
I thought it was a lot of fun I can't
wait for him to make more of these games
they're so cool I don't know I don't
know it's weird
ah alright so I'll see you in the voting
section that's a new outro you like it
doesn't matter if you don't hate alright
here we are at the voting section are
you excited
you have the face of which next horror
game that is only forgive to juice food
if I would play alright first choice I
already spoke about it was in the last
one it's called Fahrenheit for [ __ ] I
don't remember the other name it's made
by the same maker of heavy rain so if
you enjoy heavy rain I am most
definitely certain that you will enjoy
Fahrenheit the graphics are a little
weirder the story is a little darker
maybe I have no idea I don't know why I
said that all right next one is annie
shad the darkest and custom stories if
you choose to vote on this then please
leave a comment and tell me which
console story you want me to play
there's always always so many people
telling me when I play more amnesia go
ahead and suggest a custom something
that helps me out a lot more not Binks
check ass okay whatever
and the next one is a game that I just
kind of want to play but I don't think
it's good for a let's play its Professor
Layton and the Curious Village it's a
puzzle game for Nintendo des
I just everyone keeps talking so well
about the Layton games in the pulse of
games and I'm sure it's a great game I
just have no [ __ ] clue if it's good
for a let's play or not
I might have to investigate more on this
if it's actually a good idea or not same
thing goes for Gregor Horror Show
I had my eyes on this game a year ago
and then I kind of just forgot about it
it's not a horror game
it has horror in the title but it's not
a horror game you know so don't vote for
it if you want me to play more horror
you know the third option is actually a
horror alternative it doesn't look like
it but it's actually RPG Maker which is
the same engine for a engine I don't
know what to call it honestly that it
was made in and there are some similar
stores to it I don't know I don't think
there is good as if I mean it was really
amazing but you know maybe they come
close or are still getting in their
horror and the same kind of goes there
there are a lot of them so if you want
to vote me to play something similar as
em then please suggest me with which one
as well that you want to wanted me to
play feel free to click more than once
it doesn't really matter I think that
clicking will be accurate anyway it
usually comes out pretty well
please leave me feedback as well because
I'm going to draw an overall conclusion
of the feedback I get along with views
and stuff like that so I can get an idea
what you bros want to see thanks for you
for part thank you for participating in
this it really helps me out a lot
and I'll see you in next awesome life
playing all right love you both
[Music]
I'm Rufus T
I prefer said the microphone does that
make sense